>>> WELCOME, MA'AM.
CHECKING IN?
>> YES, I AM.
IT'S JUST -- OH, GOSH.
I FORGOT MY CREDIT CARD.
I MUST HAVE LEFT IT IN THE
LIMOSINE.
IS THAT OKAY?
CAN YOU TRUST ME?
>> NO, I CAN'T.
>> I'LL HAVE IT IN A COUPLE
HOURS.
>> COME BACK IN A COUPLE HOURS
THEN.
ALL RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW YOU.
I'M TRYING TO RUN A BUSINESS.
>> COMING SOON TO HBO.
BLACK LOTUS.
ALL THE INTRIGUE, NONE OF THE
FOOLISHNESS.
>> THESE LADIES ARE GOING TO BE
VISITING ME OVER THE NEXT FEW
DAYS, SO IF YOU COULD GIVE THEM
A SPARE KEY.
>> HEY, WILLIAM!
GIVE THESE HOES A SPARE KEY TO
THE ROOM.
EVERYBODY, TREAT THESE HOES LIKE
THEY'RE REGULAR PEOPLE.
>> SIR, YOU DO REALIZE GIVING
THEM A KEY ALLOWS THEM TO CHARGE
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO THE ROOM?
>> YES, IT'S FINE.
>> OH, IT'S FINE.
SO YOU RICH, RICH THEN.
>> EIGHT WEALTHY TOURISTS, ONE
LUXURY HOTEL, AND A STAFF WHO
HAS NO TIME FOR THIS NONSENSE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, SIR.
WILL YOUR FRIENDS BE JOINING US,
OR IS HE STILL UPSTAIRS
[ BLEEP ] YOUR WIFE?
>> I GOT NEXT.
>> CAN WE BORROW A SCOOTER
OVERNIGHT?
>> WE DON'T HAVE SCOOTERS.
I CAN OFFER YOU THE HOTEL'S
CHRYSLER 300.
BABY, IS THE CAR OUT?
>> WHY DON'T YOU LOOK YOURSELF.
>> BECAUSE YOU WERE THE LAST ONE
TO TAKE IT OUT.
>> JACK IS TAKING ME OUT TO THE
COUNTRY SIDE TODAY.
>> TO THE COUNTRY SIDE, DIDN'T
Y'ALL JUST MEET SM.
>> YEAH, CRAZY, RIGHT?
>> WE'RE GOING ON AN ADVENTURE.
>> Y'ALL HAVE A GOOD TIME.
HE GOING TO KILL HER.
>> UH-HUH.
>> AND A STAFF THAT'S HAD
ENOUGH.
>> EXCUSE ME.
I'M SORRY.
I'M HAVING A BIT OF A CRISIS.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE I COULD FIND A
PSYCHIC OR A FORTUNE TELLER?
>> I FORTUNE TELLER?
NOT IN HERE.
THIS IS JESUS' HOUSE.
>> I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
I GAVE HER $50,000, AND SHE
TOTALLY PLAYED ME.
>> OH, MY GOD!
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
WHAT DID YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN?
THERE'S PLENTY OF HOES OUT THERE
THAT NEVER SLEPT WITH YOUR
POPPY.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH A
REAL ASS.
>> A REAL EXOTIC LOCATION LIKE
ATLANTA, WASHINGTON D.C., AND
ITALY.
>> HEY, BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'LL LET ME SING TONIGHT,
RIGHT?
I'M GOOD.
I PROMISE I WON'T LET YOU DOWN.
>> YOU WANT TO SING?
YOU THINK YOU CAN REPLACE KENNY
IN THE KIRK FRANKLIN LOUNGE?
♪ SUPPOSED TO DO IT RIGHT ♪
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, I THINK I'LL
SIT THIS ONE OUT.
>> I THINK THAT WOULD BE BEST,
YEAH.
>> I PAID FOR THE COPA SUITE, SO
I SHOULD GET THE COPA SUITE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S SO
DAMN HARD.
>> SIR, LIKE I TOLD YOU, IT'S
NOT AVAILABLE.
>> WELL, THEN MAKE IT AVAILABLE,
MORON.
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT,
NO, NO, NO.
DON'T TALK TO HIM THAT WAY, ALL
RIGHT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WELCOME TO BLACK LOTUS,
BITCH.
>> BLACK LOTUS, BRING YOUR HOST,
BRING YOUR DESIGNS, BUT DON'T
YOU DARE BRING AN ATTITUDE
>> FOLKS, A FOUND A BODY ON THE
BEACH.
DID ANYBODY SEE ANYTHING?
>> NO.
>> NOBODY SAW A BODY WASH UP
FROM THE OCEAN?
>> IS THE OCEAN A HOTEL?
BECAUSE I WORK AT THE HOTEL.